major search engines can still collect
information about your interests even if
you don't click on the search results
directly so how does this happen for
instance Google offers a convenient tool
for websites called Google analytics
this effectively offers easy to use
reports about visitors popular and
unpopular Pages how users are navigating
the sites in general and all the data
you store so the more time you spend on
websites that use Google analytics the
more accurate your digital profile will
be and this means that Google can point
more and more targeted ads towards you
do you want to have a look at what
Google thinks about you well it's really
easy just click the link in the comments
and you'll see yourself Through The Eyes
of the search engine itself
[Music]